[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i can't run down the resume it's too
long
all i know is one of the great people
i've ever met in this business
and uh hall of famer dr j julius irving
on the program doc how are you this
morning
hey dan i'm good man how are you doing
i'm doing okay
last time you dunked last time
i was 63 years old 71 now
i i've never been incentivized since uh
since i was 63. so you know what the
hell
yeah i was wondering about that like at
what point do you go i don't
need to want to or it hurts too much to
try to dunk
it hurts too much to land after the dunk
how old were you plus plus you know i
have i have sons who play a little
basketball
and uh you know one is six six and the
other one's about six
three so i i enjoy watching them do it
as opposed to me getting out there
messing around how old were you the
first time you dunked
oh man you know i cheated i was i was in
elementary school and i was on an
eight-foot basket
and i had all i had a a small basketball
so i was doing all kinds of tricky stuff
i think a lot of stuff that people saw
me do on a 10-foot basket
started on that eight-foot basket and
then progressed to a nine-footer
and then eventually got to be a
10-footer so my my 10-foot
10-foot dunk shot my dump on a 10-foot
basket
was probably at 15
you know 1415 somewhere in there but who
did you look up to when it came to
dunking because i was trying to think
prior to you unless it was guys
playing in the rucker league or connie
hawkins or some of those guys
who was the guy you looked at well
in my neighborhood roosevelt long island
small community 15 000 people
when i walked to school every morning i
had to go past the house
of jumping johnny green
and he played for the knicks and johnny
wasn't a high scorer
but he would get a lot of tip-ins and
tip-dumps
so when i was blessed to go with my
salvation army basketball team to a
knicks game
and sit in the obstructed view seats in
the old madison square garden
so you had to look around the pole to
see what was going on down on the court
uh i was he jumping johnny green and
uh you know he was he was very
inspirational to me
um as was you know wilt chamberlain and
the great elgin baylor well i remember
jumping johnny green with the royals
and uh i think i think johnny played at
michigan state but he wasn't
he wasn't a tall guy but you know when
your name is jumping johnny you better
be able to jump
really hard yeah six five you know they
probably listed them at six
six as they did back in the day or gave
you an extra inch
you know just for the cushioning in your
shoe and the socks
and uh but he was the nicest guy
and he became a uh a franchise owner
mcdonald's franchise on i believe uh
after post career
hired some guys from the neighborhood
and i used to always visit his place and
and see him he always greeted you
graciously and with a smile he was
he was just a super guy man he was a
super role model to have
i've i guess i've taken this for granted
but i don't
remember how you officially got your
nickname dr j
i thought it was from a high school
friend but can you
tell me that story after all these years
i don't think i've ever asked you how
you got your nickname
no uh there's two parts to it
one uh initially it was just
the doctor and i had a buddy and i
called him the professor
and he called me the doctor and we have
professional sounding nicknames
his real name's leon sanders quakerly on
saunders now
and and we finished at roosevelt high we
go to umass together
so the nickname spread a little bit
while i was in college
although it was never totally publicized
and then after college when i signed
with the virginia squires
i started playing in the rucker league
uh
name got more popular then because i had
an immediate impact on pro
basketball in the summer and then when i
went to camp with the
virginia squires they had about two or
three guys in the organization who did
they just called doc and you know so if
you yell
doc in a certain room and three three
docs were in there
everybody turned around how are you
talking to me
so my trainer said you're going to be dr
j
because we got charlie scott here and
we're going to promote you guys as
charlie the great scott
and julius dr j irving and it has stuck
since
that time that was 1971. what were you
called in the rucker league
what was your nickname there uh they
they tried to
lay a couple of nicknames on me you know
you might have heard
they wanted to call me the claw and uh
they want to call me
black moses and the guy with the guy
you know the games went on in perpetuity
because you know they always
held the clock back that's why the
scores were so high in the 150s 160s
and he would just he would just amuse
himself
and pluck a name out of the sky and say
oh man the claws hit the baseline again
and dumped another one
whatever so i had to go over and say if
you're going to call me anything just
call me the doctor because i didn't i
didn't really like the other day
yeah black moses is like you can't go
home
you know and say you know to your family
you know it's i don't want you call me
julius it's black moses now
no and then i didn't want i didn't want
the whole harlem community calling me
black moses even thinking i was a
messiah
that was going to save them did you ever
i don't know if you ever fought this
um i was fortunate to see you play
against the kentucky colonels
i think was the oh wow yeah and
i always wondered because we viewed you
as a dunker
but i don't know if you fought that
label of
being just a dunker even though you were
far more than that but
that's how we came to really realize who
you were
but when you went to the nba were you
fighting that hey i'm more than just a
dunker
well it's a good conversation
uh to have because i always prided
myself
in having an all-around game
uh you know when i retired from
basketball
i played professionally for 16 years
and as it turned out i was third leading
scorer only behind kareem and
will chamberlain
they weren't all dunk shots
in terms of steals blocks
uh scoring uh rebounding
now there may be a top 20 rebounding but
top ten in all three of the other
statistical categories so i don't think
you get those type of stock uh
stats from just being one dimensional
and i've seen some guys
you know who were just dunkers and they
got a breakaway dump
i mean they were satisfied that they had
done their job
and that's all i they just brought me in
the game to get a dunk shot and then
you know sit back down you know my job
was to lead
uh to be inspirational to not only my
teammates but to the fans
uh be a coach on the floor and
uh and and do do a lot more and then
after that's done do some more so
so uh so i approached it as uh as a job
and uh tried to have a really good work
ethic that would inspire others
and even you know when i was hurt
uh you know many times i i played hurt i
think after the first year or second
year
you know nobody nobody doesn't have some
sort of pain
or some sort of agony associated with an
injury that's just not going to heal
so you know so i'm not a big load
management
uh promoter
management these days because so many
guys did play hurt
and felt as though hey if i sat down
somebody was going to come and take my
job did you ever feel bad for michael
cooper with that dunk
and in the nba
last week and uh you know we yucked it
up a little bit about it
uh since we're both coaching the big
three uh
ice cube league you know we've been able
to to make amends
uh you know he's he's been really cool
about it because he said it keeps him
relevant
irrelevant to the next generation and
the next generation and next generation
because he because he was posterized on
that particular day
and uh and i kind of agree with him
well did you think that was more
impressive or the one where you went
baseline and came up underneath
uh in the nba finals
i think definitely the baseline move uh
you know that was that was truly
floating on air
and creating uh using some
body control using the big hand to hold
the ball out
out of bounds and then you know
force of nature kareem abdul-jabbar was
standing under the basket
and it it froze him for a sec because i
mean it's something he probably could
have easily
had blocked but he didn't know what was
going on
he didn't think you were going to get to
the other side he was a little dazed and
confused
at that time what'd you like to fly
uh it's a good feeling it's a good
feeling um dan you know actually you
know it started
on the playgrounds of long island
just uh getting into swings and going
back and forth
and hitting a pinnacle and then jumping
out
going forward and soaring in the air
and learning how to land jumping off of
a seesaw
playing on the park benches stepping up
on the bench and just
just jumping and and feeling free uh
there's a freedom of express expression
uh
associated with with soaring and then
there's an extra bonus
if you soar and you score
[Laughter]
uh is there a better dunker than you
in the history of the game uh
i think that some guys who have been
more impactful
you know i mean i'm probably on mount
rushmore
uh just as an innovator and uh
opening the door for a lot of people and
that's the way it should be i mean i
think you know the first guys in connie
hawkins and
elgin baylor and uh you know i mean so
many guys who
used to throw down johnny green
aforementioned
uh you know they opened the door for the
next generation so i would expect that
you know it has been three generations
uh since
if recount generations is 10 years
since i played this before and if you
don't see improvement you don't see
better dunkers then what's going on with
these guys
you know what's once they see it they
they see as possible
and then they can take her with it to
make it better so that's that's just a
natural progression of things i think
did you think you were better than
jordan at any point
uh in the beginning you know it was
interesting because uh when he came out
of college and
we actually uh he and dominique wilkins
went to an event
in atlanta georgia and it was a
golf event we ended up getting in the
gym and playing some basketball
you know so i saw what he had but i also
knew what i had
and whatever so you know it was like he
was a junior version
uh but as you know time will tell and
the story will be told i mean that's a
six-time championship time mvp
or whatever he certainly surpassed my
accomplishments
almost doubled uh you know uh in
championships because i had three and
three runner-ups
and i'm like the gary player who says
you know i
i won the masters five times and i was
running up five times
had to include that like that's pretty
important
when you come in second uh but
most important if you validate you know
your presence and your career
by uh by getting over the hump and
that's why it was such a challenge for
me
you know from 1971 to 1981
you know with all the accolades in the
uh in the in the aba it was important to
be
mvp in the nba in 81 and then champion
in the nba in 83 because
you know there are some people on the
other side of the tracks who only look
at
that side we're talking to dr
j the uh hall of famer coolest thing in
your office is what
coolest thing about i got some stuff in
here you know i mean i i
got an emmy for the doctor a documentary
i got a nice la lique a statue of a
golfer which is
you know my one of my passions and my
favorite pastime
uh these days and once i get my
my uh shoulder heeled i
can't wait to get back uh out on the
course uh
i have a i have a trophy in my office
that
looks like a heisman trophy and it was
given to me by the dallas mavericks the
last time i played in dallas
because i was in the game that welcomed
them to the nba
and upon my retirement they created this
uh this trophy and it's really cool
well you certainly got enough awards
there uh do you did you keep everything
like do you have all your your your
honor no no no i
i didn't keep everything i think bill
russell's the only guy who has kept
everything because i've been to his
house a number of times and
you know he's got all 11 uh championship
rings
does he show those off though doc does
he is
it's in a trophy case you got to walk by
it if you walk into the house
so that's the probably the best
collection that i've seen
of a former player uh for me i actually
had an auction
maybe about five years ago so i think uh
the wonderful home that i'm living in
right now is a testimony
to party companies pardon company with
the stuff
it's great to talk to you and uh i hope
you're doing well you look good i don't
know how
you know that the golf game is going to
be when you come back
yeah how's yours uh
i took a seven-year hiatus from the game
yeah my body yeah i i had some uh
some problems uh health-wise and uh
i i i love it but i i had to step away
for seven years
yeah yeah and i think it was prior to
seven years we won the golf course
together
well that was i wish to see it back out
there that was like 90
1995 19
97 no that was in utah 97
maybe the exact year you know you
see you have a lot of people around you
they don't know anything doc people
yeah all i know is i dunked on you i
mean that's
right that's all i know is i dunked on
you
it came up it came up yeah you know
that's kind of like the legend in your
own mind comment yeah
i mean i'm not lying when i say i dunked
on dr j am i
yeah i'm not the only doctor j out there
you you were the only dr j on that slab
of concrete that day
we lowered the basket to eight feet and
i just said to doc would you stand
underneath the basket and he's like yeah
yeah and i took off
to dunk on him and i said all right i'm
good i just dunked on doctor
doc didn't even know what i was doing at
the time so i apologize
[Laughter]
uh it's great to talk to you as always
doc and uh thank you very much for
joining us
my pleasure hey you got a great show
keep it going thank you buddy that's uh
dr j
dr j looks good man